what's happening reject nation Greg Alba
here John here we are going to watch a
trailer from one of our favorite movie
companies combined with Focus Features
baumhaus Focus Features called black
clansmen spike Lee joint and Jordan
Peele produced it I believe I'm driver
and Topher Grace Denzel Sun yeah well
they're all three Denzel all three main
races the firstborn before we do that I
want to give a patron of the day shout
out to Eric Oliver just wanted to say we
love you buddy had a Google hangout with
you a few weeks ago happy marriage
congratulations whatever people truly
say congratulations on it
good on you seem like you have a lovely
house when we go to San Francisco we
will crash on your couch kick you out of
your own house you can go sleep at some
air B&B we did send you a thank-you
letter per your request and also you do
have a signed t-shirt on the way I hope
to see a photo of you rocking it buddy
and if not we want it back we want it
back Warren yeah let's watch this
trailer
[Music]
there's never been a black cop Colorado
Springs we think you might be the man to
open things up around here I love it
there no oh damn spike these backgrounds
flavor
[Music]
David Grand Wizard of the Ku Klux Klan
that day to do Oh God
last time I checked what can I do for
him well since you asked I hate blacks
I hate Jews Mexicans and Irish Italians
and Chinese my mouth the gods years I
really hate those blacks and anyone else
really that doesn't have pure white
Aryan blood running through their veins
white America white officer white me
when they meet face to face and for the
white race Toronto I know
so there becomes a combined rawness
taller can you do that okay friend
smoker stuff you guys though cross
burnings marches this is fixing to be a
big year for us
[Music]
for you it's a crusade for me it's a job
your Jewish hatred doesn't piss you off
you're taking this Jew lie detector test
why are you acting like you in the game
[Music]
[Music]
that comes out on my sister and dad's
birthday oh man I know where I'm taking
my sister I mean it looks like it will
probably be a rousing time I'm excited
for a spike Lee joint
yeah me too excited for that that looks
really cool there's a another plum house
movie
I mean it's get out know the movie where
he makes the black guy makes the phone
call and he does a white voice let's
just say 24 I don't think that's not a
24 yeah sorry to bother you yeah David
Cross and I mean that's a big plot point
for that and it's a plot point here but
that one's like a keeps everything yeah
yeah he just does that chipper white guy
voice so well in this there's a few
directors around who I think can pull
off this story yeah and could do it with
like a certain amount of rhythm and
flavor but also take it - probably the
depths it needs to go - definitely
that's Spike Lee territory right there
the combination is Spike Lee directing
and Jordan Peele producing after Jordan
peeling off the heels of Ted out doing
this subject of a movie just hearing
that alone if I heard just I didn't know
what this about the title makes you
think of that Dave Chappelle feature
like Spike Lee he can sometimes do that
where he has this sort of 70s touch out
so but it takes place in that era
it looks like the 60s 70s era has that
black exploitation by John David
Washington looks like
to kill a performance it's it's an
interesting toner striking here for a
true story if I were to hear this plot I
wouldn't expect such a dark humorous
tone
yeah something looks more like Detroit
is what I would have accessory is gritty
reading but there seems to be like dark
whimsy about it which makes it kind of
appealing and there's very few directors
who I think for this subject matter who
can get away with that Adam driver I
imagine that's a cool role for him to
take on because it's the last place
you'd expect Topher and I'm hoping that
this might be one of those roles that
shows he can you know do a different
dimension that's an easy opportunity to
be hateable
Spike Lee can sometimes get borderline
preachy with some of his movies
yeah I feel like this could be a
territory though where he can get away
with it yeah yeah and there's a certain
amount of fun and intrigue just with the
premise in and of itself inand did it
say halfway through that this is based
on some real like yeah I think in that
way you know it's a larger one of those
larger-than-life life stories to a
degree one of those true stories it
seems so outlandish and I feel like you
can kind of infuse the fun on one of
those yeah I feel like there's probably
gonna be as with any true story is
certain amount this truncated or change
a really eccentric true stare you know
and I feel like you have more license
with those stories I get the impression
that even though this tone it kind of
has this like 70s black exploitation
vibe of a trailer and I'm sure the movie
will have that in in its essence I
imagined the last half of this will
probably get very dark I met probably
more serious more tension oh yeah
trailer this trailer is fun it's kind of
like Park and he sounds so much like
Denzel he has that quality to his voice
work like if you closed your eyes well
establish Cohn
over the phone we'll need a white
officer to play me when they meet face
to face the voice does but I don't know
the face his mannerisms don't really
seem like I'm looking at Denzel but if
it was boys yeah which is good I want
him to carve his own thanks guys for
recommending that trailer to us that was
yeah you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
Belsen you're notified every time one of
our vids is up check us out on patreon
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
is shoot a lot for that so go check us
out over there